qu'est-ce que vous pensez des reproches
de certains parisiens qui disent que
l'on va détruire l'un des plus beaux
sites de Paris pour moi c'est
complètement ça m'est complètement égal
[Musique]
brodrion aujourd'hui vous parlez des
marchés et singulièrement des marchés
parisiens dans toute la France les
marchés couverts dont la majorité date
du 19e siècle sont menacés de
disparition ils sont détruits pour être
remplacés par des marchés plus modernes
à Paris rien qu'à Paris 17 marchés
doivent être détruits dans les prochains
mois donc 4 rapidement il s'agit du
marché Saint-Germain où nous sommes
celui des Batignolles le Carreau du
Temple et le marché 50 alors évidemment
une grande polémique s'est développée à
ce sujet
il y a les défenseurs des sites et du
passé il y a les commerçants qui ont
leur mot à dire il y a l'administration
et les élus qui a aussi un autre point
de vue et le débat vous le verrez n'est
pas si simple que cela on ne peut pas
examiner cette affaire uniquement dans
une optique contemplative alors
suivez-nous dans les marchés parisiens
[Rires]
c'est cela le marché une fête une fête
dans la rue tous les jours à Paris comme
en province ces marchés sont souvent
abrités dans des bâtiments anciens
vastes aérée et dont l'architecture nous
est familière
c'est le cas du marché des Batignolles
dans le 17e arrondissement du marché de
Saint-Quentin près de la gare du Nord du
marché Saint-Germain construit par
Blondel au début du 19e siècle et du
Carreau du Temple dans le troisième
arrondissement
ces bâtiments vont disparaître et être
remplacés
[Musique]
le marché aux fleurs installé au bord de
la Seine n'a pas de toit pour l'abriter
mais il est paraît-il lui aussi menacé
alors le seul marché couvert protégé
pour l'instant et celui de la place d'un
livre
vous avez c'est pour s'élever contre ces
transformations que l'association SOS
Paris a décidé de lancer une campagne
d'information son président Henri Fabre
Luce en explique les raisons
à notre avis non d'abord parce que la
ville n'a envisagé aucune alternative à
destruction pure et simple et en
particulier aucune réhabilitation n'a
été envisagée et même je dirais plus
loin c'est qu'aucun entretien n'a été
fait de ces bâtiments pendant très
longtemps on peut se demander si c'était
pas pour justifier après coup la
démolition pure est simple en disant que
c'était des bâtiments qui étaient en
mauvais état ce qui est quelquefois vrai
parce qu'on les a pas entretenues
quatre points madame Monsieur Bernard
rocher conseiller municipal de Paris et
qui s'occupe des problèmes d'urbanisme
répond d'un côté il y aurait un certain
nombre de Parisiens
conscients de l'intérêt que représente
les monuments anciens de leur ville
parisien groupé ou non en association
qui veulent à tout prix sauver les
éléments les plus intéressants les plus
caractéristiques du pari d'une certaine
époque
ils n'ont pas tort mais de l'autre côté
on présente des conseillers de Paris
présumés inculte présumé connaissant mal
les questions dont il traite et
désintéressé d'une manière générale de
ces problèmes de conservation de de
sites mais à mon avis ce n'est pas
tellement là que se situe la question la
question tient au fait que les terrains
sont chers dans Paris les terrains
disponibles sont rares et que l'on peut
penser et pas stupide de penser que à
l'occasion de la reconstruction de ces
marchés on a la chance peut-être de
pouvoir implanter dans des quartiers qui
en sont dramatiquement dépourvus parce
qu'il s'agit surtout de quartier
centraux dans lequel il n'y a pas de
terrain que l'on peut implanter à
l'occasion de la rénovation de ces
marchés des équipements nécessaires je
pense à des crèches je pense à des
garderies je pense à des piscines et des
gymnase avec le club pour personnes
âgées et c'est à ce souci que correspond
les projets qui sont souvent très
critiqués mais qui ne sont pas
nécessairement absurdes dans leur
conception parce qu'ils vivent justement
apporter à des quartiers qui en ont
besoin des équipements qui leur manque
des équipements sociaux supplémentaires
peuvent en effet justifier ces nouveaux
marchés et si le Carreau du Temple je
marchais Saint-Germain en bénéficieront
ce n'est le cas ni pour le marché des
Batignolles ni pour le pavillon de
Saint-Quentin celui-ci sera remplacé par
un hôtel de trois étoiles deux étages de
parking quant au marché il sera recasé
dans le bâtiment et ne coûtera rien à la
ville
on gagne notre vie à notre âge on peut
pas s'en aller on est trop vieux
maintenant pour trouver quelque chose
ailleurs et que tout au moins qu'on
fasse le nécessaire pour pas qu'il
démolissent en rénove et qu'on redonne
des places libres je suis pour la
rénovation du marché 50
premièrement les commerçants vivent dans
de très très mauvaises conditions de
froid de saletés les marchandises
exposées à beaucoup d'intempéries il est
bien évident que nous ne pouvons pas
continuer dans le contexte actuel de
commercialiser des produits de haute
qualité dans ces conditions
au Batignolles pas d'équipements sociaux
ce n'est pas normal la ville devrait
être plus exigeante avec le promoteur et
les commerçants premiers bénéficiaires
de cette opération sont tout de même
assez partagées le problème de la
clientèle c'est l'inconnu total alors ça
on ne sait pas du tout ça suivra pas ça
c'est alors ça c'est l'inconnu ça ça
c'est absolument pas ce qui se passera
de ce côté là
vice-président du syndicat des marchés
couverts pense différemment
on peut dire que le cadre du marché
actuel ne nous permet plus de faire
notre métier normalement et d'apporter
au public tous les services qu'il en
attend et globalement pour l'ensemble
des marchés parisiens vous qui avez les
responsabilités dans ce domaine
vous pensez qu'il faut repérer de la
même façon oui mais il faut il faut
opérer d'une de la même façon mais il
faut surtout opérer en collaboration
toujours constante avec les commerçants
eux-mêmes afin d'avoir un outil de
travail qui correspondent vraiment aux
nécessités de l'utilisateur et du public
au Carreau du Temple les commerçants eux
ne veulent pas de la transformation de
leur marché
exceptionnellement aujourd'hui
essayez-le ils sont en 360 à vendre
chaque matin des vêtements des
chaussures et de la Maroquinerie le
projet leur permettra de continuer à
marchander mais il refuse d'avoir
au-dessus de leur tête un gymnase une
crèche une école maternelle une
bibliothèque un foyer pour personnes
âgées etc
on vous a proposé un nouveau marché de
détruire celui-ci et vous n'êtes pas
d'accord pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
d'accord parce que nous aimerions
d'abord conserver ce vieux marché qui
est un
sans doute à un des derniers marchés de
métalliques de Paris et qui est sans
doute une des dernières constructions
également de ce même genre qui reste à
Paris du 19e siècle et si on resterait
tout ça c'est-à-dire si on rasait tout
ça pour quelque chose de neuf vous
auriez vous auriez quelque chose de plus
accueillant de plus propre non
croyez-vous que le un bloc embêtant soit
plus accueillant que les gays
construction du 19e siècle vous pose la
question moi je ne le crois pas
le pavillon du temple a été construit
sur le modèle des pavillons de Baltard
qui ont disparu des Halles nous avons
consulté un spécialiste de la
construction métallique monsieur roder
qui nous donne son avis sur l'état du
carreau du temps
on peut absolument pas utiliser l'état
de cette structure pour prétendre à sa
destruction ça veut dire que c'est bon
état c'est en bon état ça a été
relativement mal entre du notamment les
derniers temps mais quelque part que
vous en regardiez vous constaterez que
les travaux à faire sur les travaux
d'entretien normal
plus ou moins
certainement pas le prix le prix qui a
été énoncé pour être autre chose à la
place probablement moins même que de le
détruire et à construire est-ce que
c'est un bâtiment qui coûterait cher
je craque à construire on ne trouve
personne pour le faire vous avez vu les
détails les détails des arcatures des
chapiteaux vous avez vu la manière dont
ça a été fait c'est un travail que on ne
se donnerait plus de mal de faire
maintenant
le marché Saint-Germain est une vieille
affaire projet contre projet se sont
succédé et un concours organisé dans des
conditions particulières a néanmoins
permis de choisir un plan d'aménagement
qui a notre avis est plutôt satisfaisant
mais pas pour tout le monde
pourquoi vous voulez garder le marché
Saint-Germain éviter qu'on le transforme
c'est pas le la volonté de ne pas faire
transformer ce marché qui domine c'est
plutôt la volonté de le conserver
essentiellement de conserver les
marchands qui sont le l'élément
essentiel de l'animation car depuis que
l'on parle de la destruction du marché
il y a eu deux projets en fait un projet
d'informateur privé que nous sommes
arrivés à dégoûter par l'ampleur de du
mouvement qui s'est créé autour de la
défense du marché et le deuxième c'est
le projet de l'administration qui
cherche à concentrer dans cet espace un
maximum d'équipements collectif qui
effectivement font défaut à
l'arrondissement mais qui nous semble
absolument pas nécessaire de concentrer
en un seul endroit
l'essentiel d'un équipement collectif
est d'être au moins accessible par les
populations que ça concerne et
bien
de défense du marché Saint Bernard bien
nous venons de l'entendre mais
commerçants ne sont pas favorables à
l'association et à votre position
comment expliquer vous cela il se
rendent pas du tout compte d'une chose
c'est que si on accepte de les maintenir
sur place c'est quand même largement
l'un des effets de l'action que nous
avons emmené puisque l'un des éléments
de notre revendication c'était le
maintien des commerçants
Ivan Christ spécialiste de
l'architecture du 19e siècle nous donne
lui aussi son avis
toutes les choses du passé disaient
monsieur Giscard d'estains doivent être
traités avec égard parce que si l'on y
touche elle disparaisse à jamais et il
faut être à auparavant sur que ce ne
sont pas des choses significatives et
belles le marché Saint-Germain le marché
Saint-Germain a-t-il une chose
significative du mois qui peut le
redevenir et qui peut redevenir
également une chose belle
deux écoles s'affrontent celles qui
pensent que les équipements sociaux
doivent être concentrés au même endroit
et celle qui estime comme Christian De
Villers urbaniste qu'il vaut mieux les
disperser
quand il existe de quelque chose grande
qualité d'abord c'est dommage de le
démolir ne serait-ce que sur le plan
économique et ensuite
les projets qui sont faits pour à la
place des marchés sont des projets d'une
nature complètement différente c'est à
dire que
on supprime ce caractère de lieu public
ouvert non programmé à la disposition
des gens et on remplace par une
superposition d'équipement qui vise à
rentabiliser l'usage du sol à l'extrême
par exemple en empilant un parking une
maternelle une maison de vieillard
une bibliothèque une piscine et que
sais-je alors que ces équipements au
lieu d'être impacté dans un espèce de
monument
qui remplace les marchés pourraient très
bien être dispersés et serait beaucoup
mieux dispersé et intégré dans le
quartier
ne serait-ce que parce que la ville à la
possibilité de le faire la ville dispose
de terrain
ou d'immeubles qui sont parfois mal
utilisés parfois pas utilisés du tout je
crois qu'il ne serait pas mauvais
également à l'occasion de ces opérations
de consulter quelques maires d'un
famille qui sont obligés de faire des
kilomètres le matin pour mettre leurs
gosses à la crèche parce qu'elle n'en
ont pas à proximité d'interroger des
jeunes pour savoir si n'aurait pas
intérêt s'il ne souhaite pas avoir une
piscine à proximité de leur lieu de
domicile si les personnes âgées ne
souhaitent pas avoir un club dans lequel
elle puisse vivre dans des pendant
quelques jours par jour quelques heures
par jour dans de meilleures conditions
que celles dans lesquelles elles vivent
alors je pense que ce sacrifice qui est
fait de ne pas garder cet espace de
repos de détente que constitue les
marchés encore que réellement quand il
s'agit de marcher comme le marché
Saint-Quentin il est peut-être
pittoresque et curieux mais je ne pense
pas que ce soit un lieu dans lequel un
éprouve va très vite plaisir à ce à se
promener
les marchés qui ont été récemment
rénovés à Paris sont un argument
supplémentaire pour ceux qui s'opposent
à la destruction des autres
ces marchés neufs en effet
se déterminent de Saint-Honoré et de
l'Europe
ont beaucoup déçu les consommateurs et
ils ne font pas la faire non plus des
commerçants
quand ils ont construit le nouveau
marché et puis leur ils nous ont mis ici
dans un coin où il y a personne alors
les clients vous avez encore des gens
qui cherchent le marché Saint-Honoré
peut-être que vous avez du mal à le
trouver même c'est sûr
et il y en a beaucoup tandis qu'avant on
était à la place des pompiers dans un
centre commercial puisque la voie il y a
des commerçants et là on nous a mis où
il y a pas de commerçants pour
travailler il faut qu'il y ait un bloc
de commerçants qui ont déjà été faites
au terme ou Saint-Honoré etc ont pas
l'air d'être très probante pour les
commerçants est évident que si ça avait
été fait comme je vous le disais devant
collaboration avec les commerçants on
serait certainement sortis on aurait
sorti des outils qui seraient beaucoup
mieux adaptés alors que là il y a pas de
mauvaises intentions de la part de
l'administration mais il y a une
ignorance totale des besoins
nous payons double loyer ce qui nous
fait des frais trop excessifs pour un
marché et le marché n'étant pas ce
qu'ils étaient marcher comme autrefois
et les gens
savent pas comme il y a pas la même
ambiance de marché les prisons un peu
plus élevés évidemment les prises sont
plus élevées il faut bien que nous
rentions évidemment nous ne travaillons
pas pour rien
je ne vois pas pourquoi je vois pas
pourquoi ça serait plus cher du fait que
toutes les professions alimentaires sont
soumis à des marges soit en valeur
absolue soit avec des multiplicateurs et
peu importe le lieu où la marchandise
est vendue c'est la marge bénéficiaire
naturellement qui fonctionne et non pas
les frais annexes qu'il y a derrière
donc le consommateur devrait pas en
souffrir absolument pas
on avait d'abord trois fois plus de
place pour commencer
on avait encore
moins de courant d'air que dans le suivi
parce que ici pour être solide pour être
solide pour tenir le coup
ça a été très moche
en forains chaque année plus nombreux on
veut conserver les marchés et seulement
les restaurer
nous voyons pas un grand intérêt à faire
les marchés neufs car le marché
traditionnel dans la mesure où on n'est
pas l'ennemi de le restaurer garde quand
même ce caractère humain qui est la
qualité première des marchés caractère
humain que vous ressentez vous et que
vous préférez mais que nous ressentons
que que nos clients ressemblent car
finalement ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de travailler dans notre intérêt propre
c'est sûr mais l'intérêt des
consommateurs comment expliquez-vous
qu'il y ait des commerçants qui soient
favorables finalement à la destruction
du marché alors construction d'un marché
nouveau
à mon avis
ça me surprend un peu car finalement
pour nous qui sommes des commerçants
pour moi personnellement depuis 30 ans
on s'est aperçu dans les transformations
trop modernes qui finalement sont des
centres commerciaux et bien les gens ils
travaillent plus
comment expliquer vous que la Fédération
des commerçants annoncés dentaires
soit opposé à ces transformations
là je comprends pas très bien alors
est-ce que nous sommes allés les voir la
rue de Bretagne les gens de la rue de
Bretagne
ment je joue en jeu je l'ignore alors
le marché c'est un où il faut que les
gens circulent entre les étalages c'est
une fête le marché alors si vous le
transformez vraiment trop en magasin
alors ça ressemble plus à rien ça
ressemble à tout sauf un marché
le marché est un lieu d'animation c'est
évident et la vie n'est-ce pas ce qui
est le plus difficile à créer dans une
cité
le marché dans le quartier où il se
trouve est un élément d'animation
incontestable aux heures où il est
ouvert il est une source d'animation
pour toute la rue alentours en général
d'ailleurs le marché se prolonge par des
rues des rues marcher les gens viennent
à pied souvent faire leurs commerces là
ils achètent des choses donc ils savent
être à plus bas prix qu'ailleurs on s'y
parle on s'y connaît on a des rapports
directs avec les commerçants des
rapports qui sont souvent amicaux il y a
évidemment il suffit de se rendre sur un
n'importe quel marché pour le savoir une
fonction d'animation qui est très
importante et Dieu sait si on parle
d'animation en ce moment la nation
urbaine tu es évident de marché dans les
moments très important de cette
animation
et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on met en place
alors
9619 enfin
on a l'impression que
depuis 10 ans dans Paris on supprime un
tas d'équipements qui qui faisait la
fête qui permettait une certaine
animation de la ville pour la ville est
en train de mourir et je me demande si
la suppression des marchés participe pas
un peu de cette destruction
si c'est certainement les éléments qui
amènent des infections pour une vie
sociale qui a fait le charme de Paris
c'est incontestable et que l'on
s'efforce de recréer dans certains cas
je pense c'est au sweet très nombreux de
création de forums d'Agora pour que les
gens se rencontrent mais je crois ce qui
est surtout sérieux parce que votre
question va très loin
ce n'est pas les lieux qui manquent
c'est la disponibilité des gens il faut
bien lire que les hommes et les femmes
qui ont travaillé toute la journée qui
sont déplacés dans les conditions que
vous connaissez ont tendance à rester
chez eux en semaine et à partir quand
ils peuvent le faire pendant les
week-ends
c'est pas une excuse parce qu'en réalité
c'est un phénomène que l'on ne peut que
déplorer surtout quand il s'agit du
d'une ville comme Paris je crois que la
collectivité se doit d'aller à la
rencontre de cette tendance il faut que
le Conseil de Paris
réexamine ses programmes et notamment la
lumière encore une fois de l'idée de ne
pas gaspiller le patrimoine immobilier
de Paris de ne pas tuer les marchés dans
leur fonction d'animation et dans la
fonction économique et que on définit
une autre politique pour les marchés
voilà madame merci la petite que là
c'est moins cher
[Musique]
2 3
la ville de Paris est pas prête à
remettre en cause sa politique sur les
marchés là
je ne crois pas qu'il fasse tirer une
conclusion définitive de cela il y a des
cas qui me paraissent évident le marché
Saint-Quentin à mon avis par quelque
chose pour à propos duquel il faut se
battre il y a peut-être telle ou tel cap
ponctuel qu'il faudra revoir alors il
faut peut-être faire une cote mal
taillée mais il ne faut pas que
l'esthétisme empêche des réalisations
des réalisations sociales qui sont
vraiment je vous la surprimordiales
[Musique]
comme les trois mousquetaires ils sont
au nombre de 4 à Paris 4 marchés
couverts à être menacés par la pioche
des démolisseurs de Saint-Germain à 50
ans du Carreau du Temple au Batignolles
le Conseil de Paris a décidé de tourner
la page on abandonne les vieilles voûtes
et les structures métalliques héritaient
de Baltard pour les remplacer par de
nouveaux bâtiments l'opération est même
plus ambitieuse on reconstruira des
marchés oui mais également des
équipements sociaux à Saint-Germain un
hôtel trois étoiles à Saint-Quentin des
parkings sur les quatre emplacements la
ville de Paris prend en charge deux
opérations les deux autres seront
confiés au secteur privé
[Musique]
on fait une opération de rénovation qui
consiste à créer des marchés modernes
on s'efforce d'ailleurs de tenir compte
des irritterata des commerçants avec des
parkings pour eux et avec des recettes
pour eux
et avec des sous-sols importants et
ensuite on construit en hauteur là où il
y avait le vide on supprime les anciens
parapluies Valta et là alors là on
construit et on construit beaucoup de
choses même quelques fois peut-être trop
de choses parce qu'on a tendance parfois
bourrer un peu les installations dans
ces marchés
le Carreau du Temple une architecture
privilégiée une manière de vendre au bon
enfant rares sont les Parisiens qui ne
sont pas venus ici pour racheter des
vêtements ou simplement pour le plaisir
de flâner aujourd'hui les commerçants
sont inquiets le projet de la ville de
Paris prévoit la destruction du carreau
de leur carreaux comme ils disent et
sont remplacement par un nouveau marché
auquel viendrait s'ajouter un ensemble
sportif une école maternelle une
bibliothèque et un foyer pour personnes
âgées
pendant pas de nourriture ici nous
vendons des vêtements et si les
commerçants c'est-à-dire les premiers
inter ici dans les autres trois marchés
de Paris eux sont intéressés à ce que
leur bâtiment soit modifié ou rénovés
nous pas du tout de toute façon le
bâtiment de remplacement qu'on nous
propose
et pour l'édification d'un nouveau
marché nous nous convient absolument pas
c'est à dire que ce bâtiment provisoire
que la Ville de Paris nous propose est
inacceptable pour différentes raisons
d'abord on nous propose un emplacement
extrêmement réduit et nous nous ne
vendons pas des cacahuètes nous vendons
des vêtements et actuellement pour
vendre des vêtements ils font un choix
considérable pour vendre des vêtements
actuellement de la manière dont nous
avons toujours vendu et travailler il
nous faut de la place or ce que la Ville
de Paris nous propose c'est un maître
nous sommes arrivés après différents
marchands d'âge déjà d'obtenir un
médecin card ou un mètre 80 c'est
absolument impossible d'exercer notre
profession
à l'heure actuelle les commerçants du
temple ont recueilli 50 000 signatures
de soutien sur les autres marchés les
associations de défense s'organisent
également leurs arguments sont
identiques il faut des équipements
sociaux bien sûr mais pas à n'importe où
et surtout deuxième critique il ne faut
pas transformer les marchés en
supermarché
[Musique]
c'est exact que dans certains cas il y
avait des aménagements notamment pour ce
qui concerne les marchés alimentaires
qui ont besoin de certaines commodités
etc c'est pas assez panable c'est pas
contestable nous l'avons jamais contesté
mais de là n'est-ce pas on est passé à
quelque chose de tout à fait différent
qui a été la Pangée de destruction
totale de ce qui existe et de
remplacement par des blocs de béton sans
aucune invention alors qu'il suffisait
de faire un plan de réhabilitation
d'amélioration d'aménagement du marché
qui aurait été infiniment moins coûteux
pour la collectivité et qui aurait
permis de conserver la structure qui n'a
pas été remplacée point de vue invention
rien inventé d'autres que c'est au point
de vue marché que c'est la structure du
type 19e siècle à l'intérieur il est
suffisait de faire des aménagements
dignes du 20e siècle n'est-ce pas il
s'agissait absolument pas nécessaire de
s'engager dans un immense opérations
démolition reconstruction fond c'est pas
un manque total d'imagination n'est-ce
pas d'une part et par la volonté de
profil un certain nombre de gens qu'on
s'est engagé dans ces opérations mais ce
n'est pas du tout nécessaire et ça les
commerçants n'ont pas compris on leur a
dit on ne peut moderniser que en
démolissant et reconstruisant alors ils
ont dit ah bon ben alors allons-y
n'est-ce pas et on leur a fait miroiter
à marcher moderne et qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un marché moderne dans un bloc de
béton ça existe pas c'est mort ça tue le
quartier alors c'est là c'est c'est la
des d'où est venu le malentendu il
s'agit pas de refuser à modernisation il
s'agit de dire que la dernière version
peut s'effectuer sans être sans supposer
qu'on démolisse tout et que on fasse
table rase et qu'on construise ce qui
sera un bloc terne comme une espèce de
chape sur un quartier qui au contraire
est animé
c'est c'est là que que vient tout le
malentendu que pensez-vous des
accusations que font les associations de
défense de Paris au Conseil de Paris
justement et qui lui reproche de laisser
partir comme ça mais c'est important de
la capitale pour des promotions
immobilières des opérations vous savez
la question s'est posée alors à un
niveau plus élevé c'est le cas de le
dire à propos des Pavillon Baltard
moi pour ma part
je vais peut-être regretter sur le plan
sentimental
l'enlèvement des papillons Baltard mais
je crois que la Ville de Paris devait
les enlever
au cœur du quartier latin le marché
Saint-Germain ne se présente pas comme
un héritier de Baltard ici le bois et la
pierre remplace la fonte et le vert
l'association de défense veut conserver
au lieu son cachés actuel en apportant
simplement quelques aménagements le
secrétaire d'État à la Culture Michel
Guy a accepté un projet de rénovation
que son prédécesseur Maurice Druon avait
refusé personne ne peut raisonnablement
dire que le marché Saint-Germain est un
beau site quand je m'en suis occupé il y
a 10 ans quand j'ai commencé c'était une
ruine et je le regrette dire qu'encore à
l'heure actuelle c'est une ruine
[Musique]
monsieur est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre la rénovation du marché
Saint-Germain pour la rénovation est-ce
que cela va vous apporter quelque chose
de nouveau je pense que ça pourra nous
apporter une nouvelle clientèle qui
n'est pas du coin déjà monsieur il a été
fait des sondages et soi-disant que la
clientèle du quartier vient de les
environs de 300 mètres alors je pense
que ça pourra nous apporter de beaucoup
plus loin vu qu'il y aura quand même les
places de parking moi je suis pour la
rénovation ça c'est normal comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure quand un truc est
propre ça attire plus les gens que un
truc qui est pas trop
c'est pas trop trop accueillant quoi ça
c'est normal puis même pour nous on
préfère travailler dans un endroit
propre que dans un endroit qui est quand
même
relativement les deux quoi ça c'est
logique
madame que pensez-vous des critiques de
certains parisiens qui disent que l'on
va détruire l'un des plus jolis endroits
de Paris c'était absolument faux
parce que il ne sera pas démoli il sera
rénové d'une part et pour nous enfin ce
qui nous concerne ce sera beaucoup mieux
ce sera beaucoup beaucoup plus agréable
d'une part il sera beaucoup plus propre
et pour les clients je pense que ils en
trouveront quand même un bénéfice ne
serait-ce que l'hiver où il fait très
froid en ce moment et ils évitent de
devenir au marché l'hiver donc on perd
des clients vous avez l'impression alors
que cela va vous apporter une clientèle
nouvelle je pense oui
mais la clientèle qu'on a l'été on leur
a l'hiver qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
reproches de certains parisiens qui
disent que l'on va détruire l'un des
plus beaux sites de paris sur l'affût
j'ai pas tellement d'opinion là-dessus
pour moi c'est complètement ça m'est
complètement égal
nous avons certainement visé sur
l'efficacité un arrondissement qui a la
population d'une ville comme Cannes n'a
pratiquement aucun équipement social on
ne peut pas réclamer sans cesse des
équipements sociaux et interdire d'en
faire quand une possibilité ça mais sur
le plan esthétique on avait pris toute
sécurité j'avais réclamé un concours
d'architectes il a eu lieu 200
architectes son inscrit 52 équipes
d'architectes ont déposé un projet un
jury présidé par le Préfet de Paris
composé d'une quinzaine d'architectes
très compétents de directeur de
l'architecture de directeur des affaires
culturelles de représentants du ministre
des Affaires Culturelles a choisi un
projet ce projet a été choisi je le
répète parmi 52 autres par des hommes de
l'art je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
accuser l'ensemble des architectes
français elle est l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires des affaires culturelles
de n'avoir aucun sens esthétique en
rénovant ces marchés n'avez-vous pas
peur de détruire des sites qui ont une
valeur architecturale certaine je pense
notamment aux Carreau du Temple
il est certain que dans certains
endroits au Carreau du Temple aux
Batignolles et à Saint-Germain-des-Prés
mais
ça c'est pas seulement un problème pour
les marchés c'est un problème pour
toutes les constructions à l'heure
actuelle dans Paris
le Conseil de Paris il avait voulu
réfléchir aurait pu regarder le marché
Saint-Honoré qui a été effectué il y a
une vingtaine d'années et qui est une un
échec total tous les commerçants le
disent parce qu'on a fait un parking en
même temps et comme le parking
évidemment c'était ce qui finançait le
marché on a mis le marché à l'endroit
qui était le moins passant le parking on
l'a mis on lui a donné à plus belle
place résultat c'est un parking ce n'est
pas un marché on peut pas tout avoir
n'est-ce pas on peut pas entasser
n'importe quoi avec n'importe quoi un
marché ça suppose un certain nombre de
choses et on a cru que on pourrait en
entassant beaucoup de choses sur le même
espace rentabiliser cet espace ce sont
des mauvais calculs car finalement on a
rien on a ni un marché ni des
équipements on a un fourre-tout qui
finalement est à quoi mort il y a qu'à
regarder encore une fois le marché ça
donne rien on avait un très très bon
exemple de ce qu'il fallait pas faire on
est en train de recommencer exactement
la même chose mercredi 8 octobre des
manifestants se sont enchaînés au grille
du marché des Batignolles pour empêcher
sa destruction un geste symbolique qui
n'a pas arrêté la ville de Paris dans sa
décision
le dialogue de source poursuit entre les
défenseurs de l'environnement et les
pouvoirs publics
[Musique]